all right Nancy is with us in San
Francisco hey Nancy how are you hi I'm
gonna try to contain myself isn't very
excited to talk to you how are you well
I'm honored how can I help okay
we haven't opened one of your books I
just stumbled across your YouTube video
where you say to run like a gazelle and
after that I started listening to your
podcast and that was a month ago Wow so
thanks to you my husband and I we sold
the land and we're gonna use that money
to pay off all of our debt Wow
yes but here's the thing we made a
couple of mistakes one of the mistakes
was I I'm gonna say this out loud I
bought a $40,000 beautiful Jeep the week
that I was laid off from work two years
ago three years ago almost and I didn't
go back to work I stayed at home had a
couple more kids and now I'm a
stay-at-home mom how can I best help you
today well I want to know with this
hundred thousand dollars I want to know
if we should pay off the Jeep or take
that money sell to keep and get a $5,000
car or something to get me around and
sure what's your household income its
projected to be a hundred and ten
thousand okay and what is the other
vehicle you have a $40,000 Jeep and you
have a what else and we have a truck a
work truck videos 12,000 euros 12,000
what's it worth right now it's worth
probably 4,000 this is 2,000 alone all
right and so if the jeeps worth 40 in
the trucks worth 12 that means you have
52 thousand dollars it's less than half
your annual income so your cars are not
way too expensive the jeeps a little
weird it's got kind of a weird history
to it and that you bought it in like a
week moment when you were like grieving
or something you kind of kind of had a
crazy moment right but other than that
it's other than that it's fine do you
like the Jeep okay that's not required
that you like it so I just wondered
okay so you have other debt other than
these two debts yes i have 71,000 of
debt including that it's well oh the
other mistake okay stop so how much how
much debt do you have not counting your
house seventy one thousand okay and you
can pay all of that off with a hundred
and you make a hundred and some change
and everything's paid for except your
home at that point and your vehicles are
worth less than half your annual income
I would keep the Jeep okay because it's
less than half your annual income and
your debt free yeah okay but here's the
thing let's go back and read go back and
if I'm you I'm gonna go back and say
okay it's just like when I went broke I
did the same thing to myself I did a CSI
on it I did a an autopsy on the patient
why did the patient die okay and I went
back and I said okay there's a dumb
thing I did there's another dumb thing I
did there's another dumb thing I did and
you need to clearly identify the dumb
things okay I'll go ahead and tell you
what one of them was here okay you can
look at them you can figure it out for
yourself but the way you told the story
told us all the Jeep was a dumb purchase
why was it a dumb purchase because you
did it as at a really high stress time
and you impulse tit to medicate your
sorrows over having lost the job not the
way you make a decision to make a
purchase you don't make purchases to
medicate sorrows you'll be broke your
whole life because there's always
sorrows you don't you never do that and
you certainly don't do that with 40
freaking thousand dollars so you go back
and you look at that you go that's I'll
never do that again I learned my lesson
and as long as you quit repeating stupid
stuff you're gonna walk out you're gonna
be fine
honored to talk to you Nancy thank you
for being a listener